yeah uh let me ask you this
um what do you what what do you guys
have um
like like 20 what's your 2021 looking
like right now
man i don't [ __ ] know i mean i
thought 2020 was going to be the year
you know so of course we all did no
remember how we thought 2019 was such a
shitty year and everybody was posting
the memes about man 2019 get the [ __ ] up
out of here
2019 was fantastic i was like yo it's
gonna get great it's gonna be better for
2020 and then
march you know the world went to [ __ ] so
you know like i said
you're playing in god laughs but
hopefully you know 2021
we get the rap radar podcast out of our
hiatus stage and we
will be back with some new interviews
and new conversations and um
just new opportunities you know talking
to artists and
you know traveling across the country
and getting these
um getting these interviews popping so
when you guys because i do think um the
rap radar podcast
as far as just raw interviews right
i feel like you guys do the best
interviews
i like i really mean that thank you man
and that's with me having to get through
elliot's laugh whenever it happens you
know
shout out to elliot the goat but but i
do think like you guys
like legit if we're like just pound for
pound who's doing like the best
interviews i feel like it's you guys
especially from like for like a fan like
i feel like you guys will ask questions
because you're fans and you'll ask those
like kind of little like super niche
off the road questions that only like
maybe like a
like the core hardcore guys will like
tap that's what really what i
appreciated about that drake interview
is you guys kind of
touched on a lot of [ __ ] that like
nobody else would have talked about in a
drake interview
yeah man like i think that's the thing
too like you can attest to this you know
at the end of the day you got to be a
fan
of and um you know i think that
enthusiasm comes up
comes across you know in our
conversation so
you know i i just i love it man and i
appreciate i appreciate the the kind
words because you know we
dedicate a lot of man hours into
preparing for these interviews and
things like that
right right yeah and he's like you said
i mean there's and then there's always
the people you interview that you're not
fans of which they're always just
it's just they're just going to be
different conversations absolutely and
you know sometimes you become a fan
of the person that you weren't a fan of
prior to so you know
just humanizing an artist and you know
getting to know them a little bit better
so
that's fair man uh anything uh obviously
rap radar still ticking the blog era is
you know let me ask you this because you
guys have one of the biggest blogs ever
by the way
shout out to you and and uh amaya and
everybody at rap radar who always would
support anything i was doing
um but you guys were one of the
gatekeepers
right yep for like eight or nine years
yeah you guys could change someone's
career
we had a hand in a few jobs hey by the
way it's crazy because i just i just
tapped in with uh 360 again recently
you were you were you were involved i i
was i remember finding him on
on a wrap right up but um but but
where is it like we always hear that the
blog era is dead right
um i mean i i don't necessarily disagree
but like obviously rap radar is still a
website you guys still post [ __ ] like
it's still around out to uh paul aka the
big homie
he kind of keeps us afloat you know as
far as that goes it's still
i think that's the beauty of what the
website still provides is like a lot of
these
domains have expired or they no longer
exist
and the archives are gone but you know
our website's still up
the archives are still there so you
could kind of go back and you know
check a post from 2009 or 2018 it's
still there
and um i feel like that's good you know
it's not what it once was but
we still have a presence and i think
that's important and you guys pivoted
unlike a lot of other people in that
space yeah you know
um i i realized where the game was kind
of going
more towards conversations and things
and you know shout out to uh
uh combat jack wrestling peace combat
uh juan epstein they were doing it and
us tell this i think we could
i think we could do this too oh you know
we just wanted to keep the brain we
could have named it anything i was like
let's just keep it for brand recognition
rap radar podcast and then
five years later here we are